Guten Morgen Linus.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer 437 vom 31. August 222 und ihr hört es schon, es gibt äh Anlass zu Trauer.
Besonders schlechte Nachrichten. Diese dieses Single spielen wir zu besonders schlechten Nachrichten und ja, Hans-Christian Ströbele ist gestorben.
Wie alt ist er jetzt geworden?
Dreiundachtzig.
Dreiundachtzig. Ja, er war wohl schon längere Zeit krank,
ist, dann fürchterlicherweise auch nicht so viel drüber äh geschrieben worden und bekannt geworden.
Ich habe vor mehreren Monaten mit äh jemandem aus seinem engeren Umfeld gesprochen und ähm,
sagte damals wenn er den nochmal in die Sendung einladen wollt, sollte der euch beeilen.
Ich hatte das dann auch auf meiner Liste und dann passieren irgendwann Dinge, die einen zu viel beschäftigen und dann habe ich gedacht, ja so, eigentlich wird's ja auch nicht sein, das machen wir lieber in Ruhe,
Aber immerhin haben wir ihn äh bei der 100 Sendung äh zu Gast gehabt. Das ist auch schon viele Jahre her, aber da war er äh noch auch aktiv in der Politik, Bundestagsmitglied.
Vielleicht ist das eine Gelegenheit äh diese LMP 10 nochmal.
Hat man dann auch gemerkt, dass er Wasser doch für ein klarer Charakter war. Ich meine, man musste nicht unbedingt immer seiner Meinung sein,
man konnte sich immer sicher sein, er hatte eine und war auch immer bereit äh sie wirklich durchzufechten und äh ja hat auch die Grünen, das ganze linke Spektrum,
geprägt, hat die TAZ äh mitgegründet und war,
auch äh im Wesentlichen Schuld daran, dass die dass die TAZ auch überlebt hat, als es ihr mal nicht so gut ging und viele schon drauf und dran waren, die,
Die Zeitung von irgendjemand kaufen zu lassen. Da hat er dieses Genossenschaftsmodell durchgekämpft.
Überhaupt äh ist er halt auch fest verwoben mit der deutschen Geschichte von Anfang an. Er ist halt so das, was man sich so unterm 68er vorstellen kann,
und war äh bei den,
äh Ereignissen der 70er Jahre, auch nicht als Anwalt vor allem äh tätig hätte. Äh RAF-Terroristen verteidigt und äh hat auch so,
komplett neue Art und Weise der Verteidigung im Prinzip äh in Deutschland auch realisiert, indem man da einfach auch,
knallhart nach,
Möglichkeiten der Gesetzordnung äh gegangen ist und äh ja ist dann irgendwann,
der Politik verfallen, hat für die Grünen das erste direkte Bundestagsmandat geholt und irgendwie auch noch weitere drei Male äh geholt hier in Berlin Kreuzberg,
Einfach in jeder Hinsicht so ein total äh präsenter, krasser Typ so keine Demo, wo er nicht irgendwie mit seinem Fahrrad äh vorne weg fuhr,
Es sei denn, es handelte sich um Querdenker-Demos, aber eher nicht.
Nee, das war also hauptsächlich natürlich bei den äh also antifaschistischen Demos konntest du dann gerne sehen. Ja die,
So Berlin Kreuzberger äh Prinzipien, ne? Immer schön mit einem roten Schal und äh und mit seinem Fahrrad,
Das ist viele Jahre her. Dreizehn oder so. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Der hatte ähm,
jemand den Fehler gemacht äh Hans-Christian Ströbel das Fahrrad zu klauen. Eine Woche später hatte der das wieder.
Ich glaube ich glaube, er hat's aber irgendwie aufm aufm Flohmarkt wiedergefunden oder so. Da kannst du ja nicht strömen in das Fahrrad klauen. Es gibt einfach bestimmte Dinge, das geht nicht.
Also hier Kreuzberg war echt der der Heilige.
Und auch respektiert von allen Seiten. Also jetzt nicht nur so eine Ikone der Linken, sondern ich denke auch in der Politik,
was ich hab jetzt den Tagesschau Prozess in Deutschland jetzt grad nicht so verfolgt aber vorstellen,
sich hier jeder eigentlich genötigt, zieht ihm da äh nachträglich Respekt zu zollen, weil er hatte auch verdient und deswegen machen wir das auch.
Gleichzeitig ist äh übrigens Gorbatschow gestorben.
Ja, das äh ist auch äh eine ein ja, ein Todesfall, der offene Weise sehr äh symbolisch zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist, ne.
Ja, allerdings. Ja, Robert Schoff war ja damals echt zu Teil des Lebensgefühls. Also ich kann mich da noch ganz gut dran erinnern, als hier so die Mauer fiel.
Und äh viel los war auf den Straßen. Ich war dann irgendwie paar Tage später in Berlin damals habe ich ja noch in Hannover gewohnt und,
Hier irgendwie so als viel los war. Es war einfach äh äh immer äh krass zu sehen an diesen ganzen,
Feierlichkeiten und dann da hing ja viel an Gorbatschow dran, ne. Also letzten Endes,
kann man ihm glaube ich persönlich äh eigentlich dafür danken, dass es in in Deutschland einfach so friedlich abgelaufen ist, ne, weil man
hätte ja auch anders laufen können. Das hätten auch totale Hardliner äh am Start sein können, aber er hätte halt niemals so eine ähm,
äh Niederschlagung eines ja in Anführungsstrichen Aufstands äh unterstützt und und deswegen hat es auch nicht stattgefunden. Ich glaube,
nicht, weil er das in dem Moment irgendwie angeordnet hat, sondern weil er einfach durch seinen politischen
Weg so geprägt durch die Begriffe Glas, North und einfach ähm ja als ich die Marschrichtung vorgegeben hat und dann letzten Endes zum Zerfall der DDR ja auch
maßgeblich beigetragen hat und natürlich auch der Sowjetunion.
Sowjet Union, ja.
Das haben sie ihm natürlich dann äh krumm genommen. Allen voran natürlich Putin. Ähm na ja,
So äh ist es nun äh gekommen, aber,
war bis zuletzt äh mit seiner Stiftung engagiert und dann hat er irgendwie auch so eine der wenigen Zeitungen äh inne, die noch äh in der Lage waren, offene Berichterstattungen zu machen. Das äh dürfte sich jetzt vor ein paar Monaten auch geändert haben.
Auch insofern eine ein weiterer äh Titan der Zeitgeschichte von uns gegangen, aber so ist der Lauf der Dinge.
Irgendwann müssen auch wir die Segel streichen.
Ja dann will ich aber auch so gewürdigt werden wie Hans-Christian Ströbele. Der äh von Julian Reichelt.
Hat sich nochmal überlegt, wie er sich, wie er sich nochmal so richtig wie es schaffen kann, sich zu unterbieten?
Er hat's geschafft, ja. Er hat getwittert, äh wer schmuggelt jetzt die Waffen nach Stammheim?
Das ist so unten, das ist so niedrig. Du denkst, ah, der ist so weit unten, der Mann, ne? Und das fände ich so schön, wenn der sich so eine, so eine so eine absolut geschmacklose,
Selbsterniedrigung, ja,
zu meinem Tod von jemandem so eine erbärmliche Person wie Julian Reichelt. Das würde mir nochmal wirklich Genugtuung schaffen, ja, das das will mir sogar auf ein
aufn Grabstein drucken lassen. Also was weiß ich was Julian Reichelt nach meinem Tod über mich sagt, schreibt drauf, was für,
was ein was für ein erbärmlicher Typ. Offensichtlich ist er jetzt unter die YouTuber gegangen. Ich meine bei den Querdenken kann er ja schon länger. Also von dem kriegen wir auch nochmal irgendwie,
Wahrscheinlich kommt von dem als Nächstes irgendwie ein veganes Kochbuch oder so. Also der Typ ist äh boah, ist der geschmacklos.
Ja, der also der weiß ja auch so weißt du, wenn du dann nämlich so ein, wenn du also so, wenn ich da nochmal ganz kurz drauf eingehen, ne, aber bei so einer historischen Person wie Hans-Christian Ströbele, ja, der die Bundesrepublik.
Ab
60er Jahren geprägt hat, ja. Die hat sich also, ne, irgendwie nach ein paar Jahren gefangen. Dann wurde da irgendwie noch mal ein halbwegs ordentlicher Staat draus. Und die Bundesrepublik, in der wir heute leben, die wurde halt komplett von Hans-Christian Ströbele begleitet und an in entscheidenden Stellen auch
prägt, ja?
Dann hast du jetzt muss man natürlich bei Hans Christian Ströble sagen, auch der hatte jetzt nicht nur Weggefährten, die sich ihr Leben lang treu geblieben sind, ne. Insbesondere wenn die Otto-Shidi und Horst Mahler anschaust, hat der früher auch schlechten Umgang gehabt,
der Hans-Christian Ströbel, ja, aber ähm oder oder sagen wir äh Umgang, der sich später als schlecht herausgestellt hat,
Aber wenn du an, wenn du dir anschaust, was welche Phasen der die Bundesrepublik Deutschland,
begleitet hat und immer auf der richtigen Seite stand, ja? Und dann denkst du dir so, det Haus so Springer, die immer auf der falschen Seite standen und ähm das ist äh.
Fand ich fand ich sehr äh spannend oder oder sehr sehr sehr bezeichnend zu sehen, was das das das die Idee diese Aufrichtigkeit und Ehrlichkeit und Prinzipientreue, ne.
Konnten die überhaupt nicht haben, die die Springerleute bis zum Ende nicht, ey. Finde ich super.
Das haben sie ihm einfach nie verziehen, dass sie das äh geschafft haben, die Straße, an der auch das Springerhaus ist, irgendwie in Rudi-Dutschke-Straße umzubenennen.
Ich weiß allerdings gar nicht genau, ob der ähm ob der Hans-Christian Ströbel das damals so hervorgetragen hatte. Äh das war ja also das ich weiß, dass es aus der Tat sehr stark geprägt wurde,
da auch damals für unterschrieben natürlich aber äh.
Es waren Vorschlag der TAZ also ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen das Ströbele auf die äh Barrikaden gegangen ist gegen diese Idee.
Nein, nein, natürlich nicht. Ähm,
Aber ich glaube die äh wenn ich das richtig sehe hat der Springer Verlag sein seine Geschäftsadresse immer noch an der Axel-Springer-Straße. Aber die Rudi Dutschke Strafe hat Vorfahrt.
Das ist äh entscheidend an an dieser Stelle. Ja, die haben dem nie irgendwas verziehen und äh das ist auch ja,
Glaube, das hat den auch nach relativ kurzer Zeit irgendwie auch echt nicht mehr interessiert, oder? Also ja, finde ich, also wenn wenn die Leute noch nach deinem Tod über dich geil fanden, dann weißt du, du hast wirklich wirklich,
Prinzipien treues Leben geführt und äh ja, insofern empfinde ich das echt als als große Auszeichnung. Die ihm da nochmal zuteil wurde.
Feedback, oder.
Genau. Kommen wir zum Feedback.
Ähm also unsere Telefonbuchsuche. Der erste äh sachdienliche Hinweis eines ähm,
Eine Hörerin eines eines Hörers war, äh dass die Polizei Hamburg auch irgendwie ein altes Telefonbuch von 89 oder 90 gesucht,
und hat ja auch den Erdgast geschrieben. Der Erdgast hat sich dann auch mit der Polizei Hamburg in Verbindung gesetzt, hat auch gesagt, Sie Sie konnten sich leider
gegenseitig nicht helfen, aber bleiben im Kontakt auf der Suche nach diesem Telefonbuch. Also wenn die wenn die Cops in Hamburg an das Ding kommen, dann kann der Erdgas
äh sich freuen, umgekehrt auch. Ähm,
Außerdem äh sagte schrieb Erdgessel noch, er musste etwas schmunzeln, weil ich ja gesagt habe, es gibt eine ERB-Ermittlung, das ist nicht eher B, sondern die suchen einfach tatsächlich äh für Erbschaften, die begünstigten. Also ähm
Also tatsächlich Erdermittlung, nicht eher B. Weil ich ja noch gerätselt habe, was denn wohl eher B ist.
RB. Ich hab's ja richtig gesagt. RB. So und ähm dann haben wir Kommentare zu äh der zu der letzten Sendung relativ viele. Jetzt lädt hier die Seite nicht. Was ist das denn hier Tim?
Ähm und zwar haben wir über IT und IT-Sicherheit gesprochen, habe ich gesagt ne, aus meiner berufsblinden.
Perspektive kommt. Warum äh.
Mal gucken. Warum kann überhaupt Leuten IT äh gelehrt werden?
Ohne IT-Sicherheit, ja? Da muss man sicher auch nicht wundern,
unter äh kommentierte Dopamin. Linus als Hagener IT Security Student an der roten Uni Bochum. So fühle ich mich
deiner Ausführung gleich doppelt getroffen. Spaß beiseite, ich denke es wäre auch sehr sinnvoll
wenn in allen Studiengängen Ausbildungen mit Programmier- beziehungsweise Softwareentwicklungsanteil auch direkt die korrekte Absicherung entsprechender Implementierung gelehrt würde. Allerdings glaube ich nicht, dass wir bei der heutigen Komplexi,
des Security-Felds ohne separaten IT Security Studiengang auskommen würden ohne, dass ein Informatikstudium einfach doppelt so lang wird. Es gibt ja,
Weit ab der Security Softwareentwicklungsbereichs noch diverse andere Themen, um die sich jemand kümmern muss.
Schöne Grüße Dopamin. Ja also wichtiger Punkt weil ich ja glaube ich gesagt habe ja IT-Sicherheit als Studiengang sollte es einfach nicht mehr geben,
Das ist natürlich Unsinn. Das soll ja als also das ist oder ist nicht richtig. Das muss ja als Forschungszweig und auch als Vertiefungszweig erhalten bleiben. Ähm insofern hat er da Recht, äh dass dass also IT-Sicherheit muss muss als Sonder, als eigener,
Bereich bleiben, aber natürlich auch die jeweilige Absicherung eben in den Informatikbereichen direkt mit gelehrt werden.
So ein bisschen wie Mathematik, ja? Also man kann Mathematik studieren und voll in Mathe aufgehen, aber Mathematik ist halt auch anderen Wissenschaften durchaus ein wichtiges ähm Mittel.
Ich kann doch rechnen. Ich ich kann rechnen. Ich kann alles rechnen. Ich finde die Mathematik sollte abgeschafft werden. Als,
Ja, ich glaube, ungefähr so ungefähr so war mein Kommentar und insofern äh richtiger ähm richtiger Hinweis.
Dann beschwerte sich Match Co oder Mechko. Sag mal Leute, hatte ich gerade ein amtliches Déj-vu beim hören der Folge?
Weil ich diese absurde Geschäftsidee mit den Überflugrechten für Meta wär'sums Grundstücke schon gehört habe, stellt sich raus, ihr habt das schon in LMP,
im Juni erzählt. Sag das doch bitte dazu, ich hätte kurz an mir gezweifelt. Ja, stimmt,
Damals, da hatte ich glaube ich schon mal davon gesprochen, dass ich da bei dieser Konferenz war und wir haben nur nachgeliefert, dass es das Video gibt. Da habe ich einfach die gleiche Geschichte nochmal erzählt. Ähm,
Ich finde's interessant, dass du nicht den den Eindruck hast, dass wir hier eh seit zehn Jahren das Gleiche erzählen, aber umso besser hm ich habe ich habe manchmal den Eindruck. Mhm.
Zum Thema Chatkontrolle hat Docker Rocker noch was kommentiert, den ich also einen wichtigen Hinweis, wie ich finde.
Wir haben ja in der letzten in der letzten Sendung über den Jungen gesprochen, dessen Vater zur Frühdiagnose per Foto ein Bild von der Verletzung des Kindes an den Arzt,
hat oder an die Ärztin. So, dazu sagt Doktor Rocker zum Thema Chatkontrolle und dem Fall mit dem Jungen. Äh.
Es gibt einen wichtigen Aspekt, der nicht aufgeführt wurde. Es haben locker 20 Menschen auf das Genital des Jungen geblickt ohne Einverständnis oder Wissen der,
der Eltern und vor allem des Jungen,
Das finde ich fast noch schlimmer als das nichts blickhaft bei Google, Apple und Co mit AI ziemlichen Blödsinn zusammenschrauben und damit über Menschen urteilen.
Wichtiger Punkt. Also muss ich tatsächlich sagen, weil deine dann dann wird also wir haben,
Wir haben in anderen Folgen auch über dieses Problem gesprochen, aber hier ist es jetzt äh nochmal besonders. Da wird also durch diesen AI Fehler ja auch wirklich diese Privatsphäre,
aufgelöst oder diese Privatsphäre. Vermutung, in der sich ähm die Menschen befunden haben,
Dann hatten wir uns äh über darüber unterhalten, was denn jetzt die ganzen ähm hey Siri, was machst du eigentlich und Alexa, was machst du eigentlich machen?
Und äh da wurde äh habe ich wohl gesagt, dass
äh Apple und Google das kaputt gemacht haben, da kommentiert aber Simon sehr korrekt die Namen von Siri und Alexa wurden von Apple und Amazon kaputt gemacht, nicht von Google, die haben ihren SS Assistenten einfach Google genannt, es sollte nicht so viele Menschen geben
die so heißen. Eigentlich einfach, ne.
Ja genau. Matthias schreibt noch dazu. Ich frage mich, ob es viele Leute gibt, die Cortana heißen. Das ist ja der Dabe von Microsoft Sprachassistent und stammt vom Namen der KI im Spiel HALO.
Angeblich ein lateinischer Name und bedeutet Schwert, also vielleicht nicht so häufig. Also ich habe noch keine Cortana kennengelernt in meinem Leben und äh.
Ich frage mich eher, ob's so Leute gibt, die Cortana nutzen.
Ja, ich freue mich, ob's nicht Leute gibt, die sozusagen jetzt äh extra deswegen noch ihre Kinder so nennen und das irgendwie lustig finden.
Du meinst äh Zoom und Windows für Workgroups drei Elfen, denn ihr kennt Cortana?
Hey Alpot, komm mal her.
Also es ist schon ein bisschen merkwürdig. Es gibt ja auch so diesen Trend, dass irgendwie, wenn irgendwelche Prominente äh auf einmal in Erscheinung treten, dass dann deren Vornamen auf einmal
bevorzugt weitergegeben werden. Da frage ich mich immer irgendwie, wie wie was für einen Prozess geht ihr eigentlich, wenn ihr eure Kinder benennt, also was was sind denn sozusagen eure
zur Benennung von Kindern. Also das kann ich äh schwer nachvollziehen. Ich meine, das ist ein schwieriger Prozess. Du hattest das ja noch nicht
Ist schon eine Abwägung,
ja? Ich meine du kannst natürlich dann anfangen wie äh Elon Musk und dein Kind irgendwie nach irgendwelchen kryptischen Abkürzungen. Das brauche ich jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Gewisser Hinsicht. Wir haben ja auch noch eine Gesetzgebung, kannst ja nicht irgendeinen beliebigen Namen nehmen, sondern na, man muss ja schon in irgendeiner Form als Name akzeptiert sein. Ne?
Weiß ich genau, wie das formuliert ist, aber so ist das, kannst du jetzt nicht irgendwie dein dein Kind Kugelschreiber nennen oder sowas? So und in gewisser Hinsicht ist das ja auch verständlich,
Weil, so ein Name muss ja auch Akzeptanz finden. Dann muss er natürlich auch als Name funktionieren,
Also er muss irgendwie sich gut äh rufen und wie sie einfach auch gut schreien lassen und äh ähm insofern ne und dann möchtest du natürlich dann schon aber auch verhindern, also zumindest ich würde das gerne äh verhindern wollen,
Wollte das verhindern, also dass man schon so einen Namen nimmt, der eher,
nicht so häufig ist, dass es nicht irgendwie jede dritte Person in einer Klasse später genauso heißt, ja? Viele Grüße an alle Leas und Lenas so da draußen und ähm.
Trotzdem aber irgendwie auch noch eben diesen Akzeptanz äh Faktor hat,
So, na ja, da muss jeder selber abwägen. Aber ich glaube, die Namen von irgendwelchen Digitalassistenten, die sind jetzt erstmal außen vor und ich glaube, äh wir werden in den nächsten Jahren nicht sehr viel neue Alexas äh erleben.
Und wenn dann frage ich mich wirklich, wie weit Deutschland eigentlich in der Digitalisierung gekommen ist. Aber das frage ich mich ja eh.
So, dann haben wir äh,
uns nochmal mit und den Cookie Banner in den letzten Sendungen äh auseinandergesetzt. Und da habe ich ja ein bisschen durch Unkenntnis äh geglänzt, da bin ich durch Unkenntnis aufgefallen mit diesen,
Unternehmen,
wie User, Sandrix und Cookie Bot, die diese Einwilligungsbanner machen. Ne, also keine Erinnerung, geht auf Webseite, kommt der Cookie-Banner,
Banner hat dann Dark Pattern, damit du auf jeden Fall doch die Cookies annimmst. Und hier jetzt ein bisschen Hintergrund von.
Azimut, sage ich jetzt mal, um nicht vielleicht die einfache äh ich denke mal,
Asim, Asi, Assimut. So, äh bisschen Hintergrund zu Neub und Cookie-Bandern.
Unternehmen und Produkte wie User Sandrix und Cookieboard existieren, weil den Macherinnen von modernen Webseiten heutzutage oft selbst nicht klar ist, was für Cookies ihre Webseite setzt. Für die meisten ist die Seite ja eher mittel zum Zweck.
Portfolio für Designer, virtuelle Ladenfläche, äh Ladenfläche für die Laserschwert-Fachhändlerin und so weiter. Diese Leute wollen und können sich oft nicht tief genug mit der Materie auseinandersetzen.
Um die Cookies auf ihrer Seite zu managen. Das liegt vor allem daran, dass ihnen von allerhand Plugins und Einbettungen die schöne Features von ihrer Seite erlauben, Werbung auf ihrer Seite erlaubt, Werbung, YouTube-Videos et cetera. Cookies unwissentlich untergejubelt werden.
Da ist dann so ein Cookie-Verwaltungsdienst ganz praktisch, denn durch ihn muss man die Seite nicht verstehen. Das Ding findet die Cookies, die deine Seite setzen will,
stoppt diesen Vorgang, bis der zulassen Button gedrückt wurde. Allerdings besteht laut den Leuten hinter Cookiebott, ein Wettrüsten zwischen den Cookie-Herstellern,
also die Cookie-Hersteller,
Cookie-Sätzern, ja? Und den Cookie-Verwaltungsdiensten, bei dem die Cookie-Produzenten gezielt versuchen, vom Cookie-Verwaltungsdienst nicht erkannt zu werden und so unblockbar zu sein?
Okay. Kleiner Anekdote am Rande. Ein zentrales Marketingargument von Cookieboard ist die außergewöhnlich,
Ihr außergewöhnlich starkes Cookie finde Protokoll. Sie behaupten 60 Prozent mehr Cookies zu finden als ihre Konkurrenz. Ob das stimmt weiß ich nicht. Aber es liegt zumindest nahe, dass andere Kuckungen
Cookie-Verwaltungssysteme gar nicht in der Lage sind alle Cookies abzulehnen. Selbst wenn man den richtigen Button findet und klickt,
auf Logbuch Netzwerk findet äh Cookieboard zwei Cookies.
Nicht zum Trekking benutzen. Ich kann euch beruhigen.
Von uns also darf man auch keine eigenen Cookies setzen? Jetzt geht's.
Na ja, es geht ja ums na ja, du kannst, nein, es geht darum, dass dass du irgendwas trackst damit.
Ja
Ja? Wir nur ob wir diesen äh unseren tollen ähm Battlebanner äh.
Schon gespendet habt. Wir gucken nur, ob ihr schon gespendet habt. Nein, also.
Der Cookie lockt sich nämlich dann auf euer Bankkonto ein und guckt, ob da ein Dauerauftrag eingerichtet ist.
Der trägt euch. So ich gucke jetzt mal, was haben wir hier.
Der kommt dann nachts in euer Bett gekrabbelt.
Ja, den werdet ihr nicht mehr los. Das ist ein ewiger Cookie. Der der.
Ewig unsere Stimmen im Ohr.
In eurem Bios. Ich gucke mal gerade ganz kurz, ich sehe hier gar keine Cookies, aber wahrscheinlich wegen meiner Cookie-Blogger, ne.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach, eine Cookies.
Also lässt sich blocken, es tut alles kein Problem.
So äh also die Hersteller also zu den Dark Patterns.
Es ist wohl so, dass das Verwenden oder Nichtverwenden von Cookies in einem Webshop ernsthafte Auswirkungen auf das Geschäft hat, einfach weil die Hälfte der Cookie Seite inklusive Werbung,
auf die spezielle Userin abgestimmt wird und dadurch eine Kaufentscheidung wahrscheinlicher wird. Es gilt also, je geringer die Ablehnungsrate, desto mehr Geld kommt rein,
Die Hersteller von Cookie Verwaltungsdiensten könnten ohne große Probleme ihrer Banner so konfigurieren, dass man damit keine kreieren kann. Tun sie aber nicht, weil viele Webseitenbetreiberinnen ihre Wahl,
eines Cookie-Verwaltungsdienstes davon abhängig machen, wer die geringste Ablehnungsrate ermöglich,
klar, diese diese Kundinschaft wollen sich die Cookie-Verwaltungsdienste nicht vergraulen und so schlagen sie ins andere Extrem um. User Centrax blockt beispielsweise
wie man die Optimrate weiter erhöhen kann. Bloggt mit mit 2 G, also die bloggen darüber. Ähm,
indem man ein einmal abgelehntes Cookie-Banner einfach nochmal zeigt. Sobald eine Userin in einer Situation ist, in der die Wahrscheinlichkeit für einen besonders hoch ist, zum Beispiel bei einem Sale wie am Black Friday.
In dem Blog versucht User Centrix den Eindruck zu erwecken. Man müsste halt genau zu dem Zeitpunkt das Banner zeigen, an dem das Vertrauen der Userinnen am größten sei.
So richtig. Über die Strategie den Zeitpunkt zu treffen, an dem es die Userinnen am eiligsten haben, wird kein Wort verloren. Dabei kann ich mir nicht erklären, warum Userin am Black Friday besonders vertrauensvoll sein sollen.
Dass sie es eilig haben aber schon eher. Okay, da hat er dann noch den Blogpost. Ich denke, das war relativ äh interessantes ähm Hintergrundwissen, deswegen.
Wollte ich das mal an dieser Stelle äh auch in in Gänze benennen, das natürlich Cookies.
In diesem Beispiel, Onlineshop vielleicht tatsächlich jemandem was bringen. An vielen anderen Stellen habe ich nicht den Eindruck, dass das äh wirklich großartig was bringt.
Ja, ich meine, dass dass ihr alle diese Dienste benutzen, ist natürlich auch insofern sinnvoll oder nachvollziehbar, als dass du natürlich einerseits es mit einer permanent,
wechselnden und ohnehin nicht einfach zu verstehenden Gesetzeslage zu tun hast, muss halt in irgendeiner Form da auch mithalten können, dass du den äh Regelungen entsprichst,
äh was natürlich auch noch mit einschlägt, was sich auch erst nur sehr langsam bewegt, aber wo schon einiges an Bewegung reingekommen ist. Das sind natürlich dann auch so Sachen wie Accesibility auf der einen Seite, aber eben auch Lokalisierung, also dass eben dann auch äh ne,
Webseite deutscher User,
kommt an, also kommt IP-Adresse aus Deutschland, willst du dann Deutsch anzeigen, aber spricht vielleicht doch Englisch. Also irgendeiner Form auch solche Sachen zu berücksichtigen. Das habe ich jetzt mal bei diesem Cookie-Button noch nicht so viel gesehen, aber hier und da schon.
Und das sind natürlich alles so Punkte, wo ich gut nachvollziehen kann, warum man jetzt solche Dienste nutzt. Ich habe da ja auch nur irgend so ein Plug-in,
irgendwie mal reingeschmissen für sowas.
Ich find's schon lustig, dass dass irgendwie so die Website hat so viele Cookies, dass keine Sau mehr versteht, wie viele es sind. Da du aber Konzent brauchst, machen wir dir ein Plug-in, was,
den Konzern abwartet, aber wir optimieren das darauf, dass du den dann doch wieder kriegst, ne? Das ist halt schon schön.
Ja ja und ist natürlich auch ein bisschen blöd, wenn du jetzt irgendwie einen Browser hast, der dann irgendwie auch mal so Cookies schneller wegschmeißt so, dann bist du auch schneller schneller gefragt und,
ohnehin hatte ich auch so den Eindruck, man wird einfach permanent immer wieder gefragt, gibt's ein paar Webseiten, die kommen,
Klar es nervt einfach alles total.
Ich habe ähm hier äh letzte oder vorletzte Woche Flüge gebucht, ne,
und da haben die, boah, war das Hunde, ne? Da da habe ich äh die Flüge waren schon teuer. Und dann habe ich die irgendwie ähm,
habe ich davon von den teuersten, die die am wenigsten teuren gesucht und gedacht okay, ruhig jetzt und dann hat der so im,
aller allerletzten Moment fürs okay jetzt buchen, war auch für mehrere Personen, ne? Jetzt buchen und da hat er so ey übrigens.
Preis hat sich geändert.
Preis hat sich geändert, der kostet jetzt tausendfünfhundert. Drück mal hier auf okay mhm da habe ich mich dann für eine andere Airline entschieden. Ähm,
So ähm Postidente hatten wir noch, ähm hatten wir noch was zu.
Oder Videoideen?
Ich äh ich ich glaube in dem äh also Video-Post. Eigentlich Personalausweis generell, das ist ein längerer Fred, äh auf den auf den du da eine Diskussion äh entfaltet hast. Ich habe das mal, ich habe das mal verlinkt. Das war der äh,
Kommentar von Imbus ist das wahrscheinlich, ne?
Großes L und ein kleines L und ein großes I, nee, kann ja nicht sein. Im Bus, ein großes Ihm, ein kleines L ist das.
Tja, gute Frage. Im Bus.
Der Link. Ne? Oder zwei im Bus.
Zwei Imbus.
Zwei muss. Ein Imbus. Nein, das ist ein Imbus, ist doch klar, steht doch da. Sorry, das eigentlich gemeint. Ich gucke jetzt, was das was gucke nochmal in der E-Mail-Adresse, was das ist.
Musst du einfach kapitalisieren in den Texten. Kann man das sehen? Oder den anderen Front nehmen.
Ist jemand aus dem Kauf-Computerclub Aachen. Eine Person aus dem Chaos, Computerclub Aachen.
Auf jeden Fall äh gibt es äh den berechtigten Hinweis und das bezieht sich jetzt nicht auf,
primär auf Postideen, sondern generell auf diese ganzen Ident äh Videoident Sachen, weil wir ja auch gesagt haben ja hier Personalausweis, alles total äh Spitze. Gibt's auch alles schon. Warum benutze er das nicht, was wollt ihr denn eigentlich hier mit eurem komischen Video-Ident?
Und ähm was wir dabei natürlich vergessen haben zu erwähnen, ist die Tatsache, dass ein Personalausweis halt für deutsche Staatsbürger ist.
Leben ja auch.
Ich dachte für Personal.
Ja für das,
Personal der Bundesrepublik Deutschland GmbH. Der Angestelltenausweis. Mitarbeiterausweis.
Denk mal drüber nach.
Der mit einer ganz heißen Sache, äh ganz heißen Sache auf der Spur. Ähm ja und äh damals, als ich noch kein ähm bundesdeutscher Staatsbürger war,
Hatte ich dieses Problem mehrfach, dass ähm du einfach,
immer wieder in diese Erwartungshaltung reingerannt bis somit ja zeig doch einfach deinen Personalausweis alles super.
Interessant, wie ich wie sehr ich das schon verdrängt habe, dass ich das nicht selber aufgebracht habe letztes Mal.
Wo man sich dann so mit Reisepass und ähm Einwohnermeldenachweisen ausgedruckt auf Papier äh,
irgendeiner Form autorisieren musst, wenn es gerade mal auch wichtig ist, deine Adresse nachzuweisen und nicht nur, dass du irgendwie lebst oder weil du geboren bist oder so, ne.
Ja und das ist natürlich dann auch für solche Onlineidentifikationsprozesse bei Behörden äh durchaus ein Problem.
Wenn man halt jetzt sagt so, wieso kann man doch auch alles äh super elektronisch machen, die Dinge sollten ja jetzt auch nicht nur für deutsche Staatsbürger äh einfacher werden, sondern im Prinzip ja für alle Leute, die hier zumindest wohnen,
ja gut daraus könnte man schnell mal ableiten dass man doch vielleicht mal drüber nachdenkt entweder den Personalausweis nicht nur für deutsche Bürger auszugeben,
weil es ja kein Nachweis der Staatsbürgerschaft, sondern es ist ein,
einen Personalausweis, also ein Identifikationsdokument kann sich ja auch identifizieren lassen ähm wenn man nicht äh Deutscher ist, zumindest ist das ja möglich. Ich meine, wenn man hier einen Aufenthaltstitel bekommen kann, dann,
Muss man ja auch in irgendeiner Form identifiziert werden können, ne? Oder man schafft halt eine technisch identisch funktionierende Karte, die nicht der Personalausweis ist, sondern was auch immer. Ähm,
die denselben Zweck erfüllt.
Übrigens Limbus. Das ist ein kleines L und großes I.
Okay, so rum. Na ja.
Sieht in unserem Front halt ein bisschen komisch aus, weil ich habe jetzt hier mal ernst in den genommen, da kann man ganz klar erkennen, Limbus.
Dass es so ist. Na ja, aber.
Kann man sich übrigens als Künstlernamen auch in Personalausweis eintragen lassen.
Welche Schreibweise jetzt? Zwei Bus oder E-Bus?
Weiß nicht, kommt drauf an, was schon vergeben ist.
Erstmal gucken, welche Domain noch frei ist.
Also ich hatte in Amerika auch einen amerikanischen Ausweis, aber keine Staatsbürgerschaft.
Ja, guck an. So was.
Amerikanischen Führerschein habe ich auch. Das ist ja also das.
Man könnte das ja auch dann gleich auf die europäische Ebene heben und sagen, man könnte ja mal eine europäische einheitliche Identifikationskarte äh schaffen,
die überall funktioniert, sodass ich mir auch auf einem Online-Dienst in Spanien zum Beispiel melden kann. Also ich halbes Jahr in Spanien gelebt habe, war auch das Problem, dass man da ähm,
klassischerweise sich mit seiner äh Steuer-IT überall irgendwie meldet.
Ja, also wenn du da irgendwie wohnen willst und Dinge tun willst, dann ist es oft erforderlich diese Nähe äh zu,
anzugeben und das so total Usus da ähm,
Ich muss dann auch erstmal kriegen, muss dann beantragen, ja, ich werde da eine längere Zeit sein und ich brauche irgendwie so eine Nummer und so, ne, dann dann dann kriegst du so was.
Das wäre ja eigentlich viel einfacher
Ähm entweder den Personalausweis europaweit benutzen kann oder eben so einen europäischen Identifikationsnachweis bekommen könnte, sodass man eben innerhalb der EU
Zumindest war alles, was so behördliche Sachen betrifft
Ne? Also gerade so wie Anmelden für, ich wunder jetzt mal und äh keine Ahnung, äh habe Anspruch auf was auch immer, dass man dann ähm oder eben so bei solchen,
Onlinebuchung, wo dann eben ne in irgendeiner Form eine Identifikationsnachweis, ein zuverlässiger äh gefordert wird, dass man dann eben,
So eine Karte nehmen kann. Da müsste es eigentlich hinlaufen und von daher sind diese ganzen nationalen Lösungen in diesem Bereich irgendwie ohnehin äh schwierig.
Ja geil, jetzt schickst du die ganzen Idioten mit ihrer äh die Wallet in ihrer Blockchain auf EU-Ebene.
Tim, nee, super. Geschäftsbetrieb für Logbuch Netzwerk für nächsten sechs Jahre gesichert. Äh nee, prima. Danke.
Hauptsache keine Cookies.
Herr Staatsanwalt, ich bin falsch verstanden worden.
Also Tim will eine einheitliche, du willst einen Bürgerausweis.
Also wie man den nennt, ist mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt egal, aber die Möglichkeit sich äh über irgendeine EU-Behörde äh nachweisen zu lassen, ich bin X und meine Staatsangehörigkeit ist äh Y und mein Wohnort ist Z und.
Funktioniert das einfach mal überall in der EU, fände ich schon mal einen Schritt nach vorne.
Ich habe gedacht, Europass könnte man das nennen äh die Domain gibt's auch schon.
Aber wieder zu langsam.
Okay, kommen wir mal zu den zu den neuen Themen.
Wie neu sind die denn.
Aus dem Internet. So und der also,
Matsch war der ITs, war der IT oder Sicherheitschef bei Twitter?
Äh Matsch ist ein relativ sagen wir mal relativ bekannter ähm Hacker äh habe ihn mal auch auf dem Kongress kennengelernt ähm,
der ähm weiß gar nicht also,
Hintergründe so äh kalt auf eine Dead Cow und solche Geschichten, also ganz, ganz alter äh Hacker-Hochall in den US,
der war dann auch so in dem wie die meisten US-Amerikaner, die im Informationssicherheitsbereich waren natürlich dann auch hier für in der Defense gearbeitet hat, die ja in
letzten Jahren in den USA eher so offense war in den letzten zwei, drei Jahrzehnten. Ähm,
dann ist er offenbar äh bei Twitter, ich glaube ungefähr vor etwas über einem Jahr äh dann da als äh IT Sec als Security-Chef eingestellt worden.
Und der hat jetzt eine ähm einem also der ist jetzt ist jetzt Whistleblower,
und äh beschwert sich bei den Aufsichtsbehörden äh über Twitter als Unternehmen mit katastrophaler Sicherheits.
Das Erste, was wir da also das Erste, was mir da auffällt, ist so, ich meine, wenn du der Sicherheitschef bist, dann bist du doch dafür verantwortlich. Also ne, das ist,
Wurdest du ja wahrscheinlich eingestellt, dass zu ändern
aber offen, der ist da irgendwie wohl unter vor einigen Monaten unter äh unklaren Umständen gegangen und wahrscheinlich, weil er äh sich beschwert hat. Also im Zweifelsfall muss man jetzt hier sagen, die Geschichte ist so ein bisschen klingt so nach einem,
Wie nennt man das? Bad liefer. Ähm aber ich würde mal sagen, das Matsch einfach besser hat als Twitter. Insofern ähm muss man dann also sage ich mal, würde man schon eher ihm hier glauben, ne und ähm.
Was war das für ein Begriff gerade, Bad?
Jemand, der das Unternehmen oder die Organisation in äh sagen wir, in in schlechtem in schlechter Stimmung verlässt.
Im Sinne von hat es verlassen lief, okay.
Ja genau, der ist gefeuert worden,
Also ähm das sind in in der IT-Security immer auch so Szenarien, also Bad Leaver. Bad Liva ist eher so ein Prozess, den hast du als Unternehmen ähm,
sieht man auch zum Beispiel in so US-Firmen gerne mal, die haben alle so ein Bad Leverprozess, ne?
Der funktioniert nämlich so, dass du beim Büro ins, beim Chef ins Büro äh gerufen wirst und dann steht schon dein Pappkarton aufm Schreibtisch und dann kannst du alles reintun und dann zeigen dir zwei freundliche Herren den Weg nach draußen, ne? Und nehmen den Schlüssel ab. Das ist dann so der,
ja? Der Good Lea kriegt noch ähm kriegt noch ein Bier und äh und Kuchen am Freitag Nachmittag oder sowas, ne? Der bett lieber nicht. Und dann gibt's ja noch den Disscrunchhild Employee,
Ist dann jemand, der äh der der mit seiner Kündigung oder die mit ihrer Kündigung so schlecht klarkommt, dass sie nach das Unternehmen noch irgendwie kaputt machen.
Gab's auch, gab's einen großen Fall hier in Deutschland vor einigen Jahren bei so einem Rechenzentrums äh Anbieter.
Der der Fall war auch äh in den in den Medien
Ähm da jetzt haben sie ein Admin gekantet und nicht zugesehen, dass sie den mal an den entscheidenden Stellen die Rut Passwörter wegnehmen.
Der hat dann äh gesagt, ach boah, ich lösche die Scheiße einfach und das äh hat äh längere, zu größeren Ausfällen geführt. Äh lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, Matsch beschwert sich also jetzt über die mangelnde Sicherheitskultur bei Twitter und wirft dem äh sozialen Netzwerk vor,
wirtschaftlichen Erfolg und Wachstum vor Sicherheit und Datennutz. Der Datenschutz der Nutzer zu stellen,
Damit hat er sich an die äh SEC, also die Börsenaufsicht und an die Handelsbehörde, die FTI FTC, Gemälde und Anziehstutzministerium.
Und äh hat dann also von internen Grabenkämpfen gesprochen,
chaotische Managementstrukturen und eine Sicherheitskultur, die weder,
den Auflagen der Behörden noch dem Schutzbedürfnis der 230 Millionen aktiven Nutzerinnen und Nutzer gerecht wird. Ähm,
immer die FTC hat Twitter aber 20100 wegen Datenschutzverstößen ähm,
Auflagen gegeben oder beziehungsweise eine verschärfte Aufsicht und da könnte eben Twitter auch äh dann verstoßen haben.
Es gibt immer mal wieder weitreichende äh Hacks bei Twitter, ja, Promi-Accounts ähm und
Matsch sagt zum Beispiel auch oder also normale User Accounts mal ganz außen vor, aber wir hatten ja auch irgendwie Elon Musk und Joe Biden wurden da auch schon mal übernommen und haben für Bitcoin geworben und solche Sachen.
Gleichzeitig sagt er ähm an den äh an den Verwaltungsrat äh hätte äh,
werden diese Sachen nicht berichtet. Er hätte das mal intern zur Sprache gebracht und wer da dann eben entlassen worden und äh kommt zu dem Fazit äh Twitter handelt im Bereich der Informationssicherheit grop fahrlässig.
Die Hälfte aller Vollzeitmitarbeiter hatte Zugang zu Produktivsystemen und Daten. Und dabei sei die Zahl dieser Leute,
die Hälfte der Vollzeitmitarbeiter und die Zahl sei im Laufe des Jahres von 5900 auf 7.700 gewachsen. Damit hatten 2tausend1undzwanzig immer mehr Personen Zugriff auf Sicherheits,
sensible Bereiche, die Server haben veraltete Körner, dass da frage ich mich so, ja gut, das äh kommt's schon mal vor.
Aber die Entwickler arbeiten am Livesystem mit echten Kundendaten, haben keine Test- und keine Staging-Umgebung. Äh das ist natürlich durchaus ein ein großes Risiko, dass eben auch ehemalige Mitarbeiter sie abgreifen. Äh,
Er rechnet äh er sagt, äh bei Twitter werden wöchentlich 30 Leute entlassen und ja, es werden 500.000 Server,
und auf 60Prozent davon laufen Betriebssysteme veralteten Körnern die teilweise sind. Ja ähm.
Auch die Software auf den Mitarbeiterrechter teilweise nicht mehr mit Updates versorgt. Ja, also,
relativ schlechte Nachricht oder eine relativ schlechte äh Nachrichten aus aus äh gutem gut beleumundetem Mund fragt sich natürlich trotzdem, warum macht er da jetzt den Mund auf? Also ich find's irgendwie,
Erstaunlich. Also das äh also in meiner Wahrnehmung,
vielleicht sitzt eine Rache dafür, dass er diese Missstände beheben wollte und dafür gefeuert wurde. Ähm aber es passt natürlich Elon Musk auf jeden Fall gut in Kram, oder?
Elon Musk. Du meinst, um weitere Argumente zu liefern, äh warum man Twitter niemals hätte.
Man den Laden nicht kauft.
Na ja, weiß ich nicht, ob das relevant ist, weil ich glaube darum ging's ja nie.
Aber keine Ahnung, was seine Motivation ist. Also kann,
weiß ja immer nicht, was da hinter den Kulissen irgendwie abspielt. Was hat jetzt für Persönlichkeiten äh sind und und wer sich da an wen abarbeiten muss, aber wenn wenn seine Aussagen stimmen, dann ist das an sich ja schon ähm problematisch.
50 Prozent der Mitarbeiter haben Zugriff auf sicherheitsrelevante Daten.
Ja wenn alle Entwickler irgendwie am Livesystem arbeiten, geht halt ganz schnell, ne?
Na ja gut, ich meine definiere sicherheitsrelevante Daten so. Das kann auch alles alles mögliche sagen, ne. Na ja. Gut, kann man jetzt erstmal nur so hinnehmen aus meiner Perspektive.
Es ist halt so ein bisschen überraschend, dass also so was machst du halt nicht, ne? Also es ist ja,
ich bin ja eben auch in der Informationssicherheitsbranche tätig und eigentlich kannst du kannst du sowas halt einmal machen, ne? Weil danach äh,
wird jetzt also dein Ruf leidet ja darunter
Ja, wenn du jetzt sagst, hier das sind aber katastrophale Zustände bei diesem Unternehmen im Bereich der IT-Sicherheit, dann denkt sich halt jeder Nächste, wir äh sollen wir uns den Matsch als Sicherheitschef holen? Der kommt nachher raus und sagt, das ist alles Kacke. Und das ist ähm.
Irgendwie,
Ich weiß, ich ich vermute, dass es da irgendeinen anderen Hintergrund gibt. Vielleicht haben die irgendeine Klage gegen den, äh dass sie ihm das jetzt in die Schuhe schieben wollen oder so. Ich ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass der ohne irgendwelchen
wirklichen Druck, eine solche öffentliche ähm,
Äußerungen tätigt, ausführlich gegenüber halt der FTC und so weiter, dass er also irgendwie macht keinen Sinn. Also,
irgendeinen Anlass wird er dafür gehabt haben und der Anlass ist unklar und äh ich denke, er wird da noch rauskommen. Wahrscheinlich also wahrscheinlich wird es ein guter Anlass sein, dass sie irgendwie versucht haben, unter Druck zu setzen oder weiß der Geier ähm oder oder halt einfach geil geiles Angebot von Elon Musk,
Glaube ich aber nicht.
Guck mal, wo wir als nächstes arbeitet.
Wir haben jetzt eine Digitalstrategie Tim.
Auch gehört.
Die haben wir schon länger. Ich muss echt sagen, das tut mir auch wirklich leid, ne. Die liegt seit also in mehreren Versionen seit Monaten auf meinem Desktop.
Ähm,
Immer wenn ich das so angeguckt habe, ah ich so, irgendwie wirklich nach kürzester Zeit lief mir so Blut aus den Augen und weil ich das einfach ich kann da ich tut mir auch leid, ne? Aber ich kann das gar nicht mehr lesen.
Trotz der ganzen SMS, die du gekriegt hast, ey Linus, lies doch jetzt mal endlich deinen Olaf. Sag mal was dazu.
Nee, sowas kriege ich auf anderem Wege. Ähm.
Ja? Pro Post the Fax.
Twitter. Aber also was haben wir? Wir haben drei Themenfelder. Wir kriegen jetzt eine vernetzte Gesellschaft.
Innovative Wirtschaft und digitalen Staat. In der vernetzten Gesellschaft kriegen wir digitale Infrastruktur
Bildung in allen Lebensphasen, Gesundheit und Pflegemobilität bauen, digitale Zivilgesellschaft, Kultur und Medien, Teilhabe und Barrierefreiheit, das wird alles digital, ja. Die digitale Zivilgesellschaft wird gestärkt.
Durch Initiativen und Projekte für,
digitale Souveränität, ne? Da sind wir natürlich jetzt hier äh äh da sind wir natürlich hier im äh TechFund in in diesem Bereich, ja. Ist ja auch alles nicht schlecht. Ja, das ist auch also,
Das ist ja schön. Wir kriegen digitale Infrastruktur bis 210 haben wir überall 50 MBit. Also.
War das bis wann kriegen wir 50 Mbit? Ich gucke mal kurz. Das war der Merkels Versprechen.
Mehrere ja es ist das ist das ist das ist so der das ist so der Karotte.
20 18 bis 20achtzehn.
Die Karotte am am Stick ist das.
Bis zwanzig achtzehn kriegen wir alle fünfzig MB.
Äh
konnte das Ding nicht lesen und ich kann's auch jetzt nicht lesen, aber jetzt ist es wenigstens etwas ähm äh etwas ansprechender aufbereitet und ich möchte jetzt also das das Problem mit so einer,
Strategie ist ja, schafft schafft man das jetzt, die mit Leben zu füllen,
Zum Beispiel digitale Polizei. Stellen sie fest, jeder Streifenwagen hat ein Blaulicht korrekt. Ist korrekt,
Doch nicht jeder Polizeicomputer hat die gleich gute Software. Ich würde sagen,
Rechenpower von einem Blaulicht hat jeder Polizeicomputer locker. Bruno Lenner verpassen den Polizeien ein Update und heben ihre digitalen Möglichkeiten auf einen gemeinsamen Stand.
Die wollen dann irgendwie die IT harmonisieren und ein Datenhaus bauen,
Kriegen Sie eine vereinheitlichte Sachbearbeitung bis zwanzig fünfundzwanzig, das in drei Jahren. Also ich.
Das haben wir alles schon mal gehört.
Es ist immer wieder dasselbe Dumscheid Berg hat sich auf Twitter auch schon äh ausführlich in so einem geäußert, was sie so meint und sie ist äh sagen wir mal Underwant so,
einfach dem ganzen Papier so Gemeinwohlorientierung,
fehlt keinerlei Vision für äh einen,
Schon gar nicht Digitales ähm geäußert wird, kein Transparenzgesetz ist, noch keine klaren Budgets,
ausgelobt werden in dem Rahmen so, was jetzt eigentlich so was ist jetzt, wenn so ein Surren Techfand loslegen möchte, ja, gibt's da Kohle für. Ist äh alles noch unklar und vor allem, dass halt irgendwie.
Nee, aber der,
Übrigens muss ich tatsächlich sagen, also dass die Kohle kriegen, das scheint mir schon ziemlich klar zu sein. Ähm ich habe die jetzt mehrmals an verschiedenen Stellen nochmal mit ähm
zum Beispiel Adriana und äh Fiona auch gesprochen, die sind da jetzt äh zugange. Also das das äh ist glaube ich das wird schon ganz gut aufgegleist und die zum Glück nehmen die ihre Arbeit ja auch ernst. Also da kann da kann schon was kommen.
Ja
Mag sein, dass da was kommt, nur ist wohl irgendwie unklar, in welchem Maße wie langfristig. Äh ich gebe jetzt auch noch ihre Kritik äh wieder, weil ich habe das jetzt genauso wenig gelesen wie du. Ähm aber es,
Simoniert halt das im Prinzip halt,
genau die selben Dinge jetzt sozusagen als Ziel ausgegeben werden, die wir die wir bisher schon haben und die wir bisher schon nicht bekommen haben, ne? So schnelles Internet,
Funklöcher weg. So Digitalisierung des äh,
Gesundheits äh Bereichs, digitale Verwaltung. Ja klar, das steht da jetzt drin, aber ich meine, wer glaubt denn das noch, dass da jetzt irgendwas wirklich hm vorangeht, ne und im Sicherheitsbereich,
Gut, es gibt so Sachen wie hm dass die ähm Haftung für Sicherheitslücken durchaus äh kommt, aber halt,
viele andere Sachen eben auch nicht.
Ja. Die andere Sache ist, ich meine, sollen sie's nicht reinschreiben? Dann würdest,
wie.
Darüber hinaus sozusagen, ja, also das ist äh man man verspricht und bekämpft immer noch das, was sozusagen schon seit Jahren äh versprochen und und und bekämpft wird und die anderen ziehen ja einfach auch
um uns herum einfach weiter so. Ich meine, es ist ja einfach mittlerweile macht man sich ja schon lächerlich international. Äh zeigen ja alle mitm Finger auf uns,
Also wo ist die wo ist die Glas.
Okay.
Ja wo wo wo ist das Ziel so ja jetzt machen wir aber hier mal wirklich mal so richtig mal ernst so der Start verbuddelt jetzt mal das Glas.
Vernetzte Gesellschaft, digitale Infrastruktur. So, hier gucken wir bis zwanzig fünfundzwanzig. Oh mein Gott,
Oh mein Gott. Bis zwanzig 52und, also in drei Jahren, ja, wird die Genehmigung für neue Glasfaser und Mobilfunkstandorte schneller und digital laufen.
Nicht digital.
Ja ist auch schön, dass man das in drei Jahren schneller machen. So könnte man vielleicht jetzt schneller machen.
Hälfte der Haushalte und Unternehmen wird mit Glasfaseranschlüssen versorgt sein, um schneller zu sein, werden Firmen, die Glasfaser häufiger nicht ganz so tief im Boden verlegen oder sogar oberirdisch führen. Dafür gibt es zwanzig, 25e entsprechende Normierung und Stabilisierung.
Ja gut, dann dann vergrab er die Glasfaser halt nicht so tief in den Boden, dann holen die halt irgendwelche Marder oder oder Hunde,
oder wer auch immer Bälle noch Löcher, Hundegrabenlöcher? Füchse?
Das macht ja durchaus Sinn, ne? Also das das finde ich ja völlig in Ordnung. Äh es
durchaus Situation, da ist eine oberirdische Verlegung vollkommen okay, wenn du jetzt da irgendwo im Wald äh hast da so eine einzelne Hütte äh stehen, da liegt sowieso schon das Stromkabel oben aufm Mast. Warum nicht einfach Glasfaser noch dazutollen und dann passt das schon. Und wenn jetzt das derzeit durch irgend so eine
örtliche Regelungen einfach untersagt ist, weil es muss irgendwie fünf Meter äh unter der Erde schmoren so, dann ist das natürlich Unsinn und dieses muss nicht ganz
tief vergraben werden, ist auch sinnvoll, ähm weil es denn eben dieses äh Slicing ermöglicht, also diese,
Diese diese Frästechniken, dass zum Beispiel so am Bordscheinrand oder sowas.
Heißt.
Microtraining. Okay, schön, schönes Wort, genau.
Gigabit Grundbuch wird volle Transparenz schaffen. Wie schnell ist das Internet und wo muss ausgebaut werden? Gigabit-Grundbuch.
Kann ich gar nicht beantworten. Das Internet ist überall nicht schnell genug und es muss überall ausgebaut werden. Also mir fehlt da der große Wurf ja weil wir eigentlich immer noch mit demselben Modell voranschreiten so ne aber das äh,
Der Staat einfach mal sicherstellen muss, dass das überall Glasfaser liegt und dass die dann entsprechend äh allen ähm vermietet werden kann, dass jeder das sozusagen vom Staat mieten kann.
Das ist halt nach wie vor gar keine äh zentrale Idee.
Also ich bin gerade, ich ich äh es gehört ja zu den zu den Gepflogenheiten von Logbuch Netzpolitik, dass ich nie sage, wo ich gerade bin. Auch wenn ich gerade nicht in Berlin bin, ne? Aber ich war in einem anderen Land und in diesem Land.
Irgendwann? Mhm. In einem unbekannten.
Eine in einem unbekannten Land. Nein, das.
Gar nicht allzu langer Zeit.
Vorher gar nicht allzu langer Zeit mit einer Biene. So und dieses äh dieses Land äh da habe ich gesagt, ich hätte gerne eine SIM-Karte.
SIM-Karte. Ehrlich gesagt und zwar hätte ich gerne eine ohne Volumenbeschränkung. Dann haben die gesagt, ähm wir haben nur SIM-Karten,
ohne Bevolumenbeschränkung. Habe ich gesagt, okay, dann nehme ich so eine, ne? SIM-Karte bekommen und dann stand da ähm,
Moment, was stand da drauf? Ein 1tausend M.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ist das denn hier? Wofür steht denn 1tausend M? Und dann haben die gesagt, eintausend Mega. Bit,
Habe ich gesagt, wie ich dachte, die hätte keine äh die hätte keine äh Volumenbeschränkung. Dann hat er gesagt, nee hat die auch nicht, das ist die Geschwindigkeit.
Ja und guckte mich so an so ob ich doof bin oder so.
5 G sind, die heißen, 5G.
Und äh wer wer wissen möchte, äh äh wie das Land heißt, in diesem Land heißt 5G Wieseke.
So, dann haben wir ähm.
Das ist doch mal ein schönes Rätsel. So, dann haben wir äh was haben wir noch? Was kriegen wir noch? Also Internet kriegen wir. Die Mobilflügerforderung wird dafür sorgen, dass Funklöcher verschwinden.
Im Jahr 2026 werden wir überall im Land ohne Unterbrechung telefonieren können,
und Daten austauschen können und 2030 werden wir den neuesten Mobilfunkstandard überall haben, wo wir leben, arbeiten oder unterwegs sind. Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, weil ich glaube, bis dahin gibt's schon wieder einen neuen. Ähm.
Wir quälen uns die Nuss. Ich glaube, wir müssen da mal eine Sondersendung zu machen.
Ja wir wir machen da mal eine Sondersendung zu des also was die die mich erinnert's ein bisschen wie die Cyber-Sicherheitsstrategie.
Weißt du? Die haben wir ja auch äh vor vor ein, zwei Sendungen besprochen. Und da steht auch drin, das wird alles sicher. Ach so, übrigens hier hä, da müssen wir noch kurz machen. Das ist nämlich super. Also das ist ja was, was mich immer interessiert, Cybersicherheit, ja?
So, weißt du was passieren wird bis zwanzig fünfundzwanzig ähm.
Bis 2025 soll in Deutschland die Cybersicherheit der aktuellen Bedrohungslage angemessen sein.
Also drei Jahre ihrer Zeit hinterher.
Bin ich arbeitslos, ja? Also genau, stimmt, der aktuellen, ja genau, nee, in drei Jahren werden wir der aktuellen Bedrohungslage angemessen sein, nicht ich denke eher die äh ja,
Ja genau, ja doch, so muss man das lesen, du hast recht. Ähm.
Mit Preview soll Bedrohung aus dem digitalen Raum frühzeitig erkannt werden.
Ja, aber okay, also wo worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist du, wenn du wenn du eine Strategie, man kann eine Strategie entwickeln und das ist gut und dann hat man eine Strategie,
Und anhand dieser Strategie muss man ja dann auch eine Taktik äh irgendwie finden,
und diese Taktik,
Wenn deine Strategie vollständig losgelöst ist von der Realität, dann äh landest du halt irgendwann bei Helmut Schmidt, der dir empfehlt, empfiehlt mit deinen Visionen zum Arzt zu gehen und,
irgendwie frage ich mich, ob also vielleicht ist ja auch all das möglich. Man muss ja nicht weit fliegen oder gucken, um zu sehen, wo Dinge möglich sind. Aber,
so ganz ohne,
wenn er immer nur Strategie und Papier, ich meine ich kann mir schon sehr gut vorstellen, dass so ein paar ähm Mitarbeiterinnen im Ministerium eine ganze Menge Papier produzieren, wo eine ganze Menge Gigabit äh möglich wären, ne, aber,
Hoffen wir wir dürfen ja nicht vergessen wir haben eine andere Bundesregierung, hoffen wir, dass die das vielleicht äh vielleicht klüger hingeht und und sich überlegt hat, dass die Versprechungen machen, die sie halten können.
Also wie gesagt, weckt mich, wenn sich was tut, aber ich ähm,
Ich habe aufgegeben daran zu glauben, dass wir das noch gedreht bekommen. Also ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, wir werden hier in.
Wie lange machen wir jetzt einen Podcast noch?
Zwanzig fünfundzwanzig, dann ist das alles gelöst.
20, fünfundzwanzig. Ja genau, ne, machen wir uns mal einen Eintrag hier, äh was haben wir heute? Einunddreißigster August äh fünfundzwanzig,
ähm mache ich mir da jetzt mal gleich einen Eintrag rein und dann gucken wir mal, ob sich irgendwas getan hat. 31. August, ist ein Sonntag. Hast du da Zeit?
Im Internet, da habe ich sicheres Internet.
Mahlzeit. Ich mache mir jetzt hier einen Eintrag rein. Hat sich am an,
an der Internetsituation,
in Deutschland was geändert Fragezeichen. Gucken wir mal. Mein Tipp ist nö.
Also nichts nichts Substanzielles, sondern wir werden nach wie vor aufm letzten
Platz ein Glasfaserausbau sein. Wir werden nach wie vor darüber streiten, wie man denn irgendwie Digitalisierung und Bildung zusammenbringen kann. Wir werden weiterhin eine äh
Bildungsmisere haben, was äh Ausbildung von IT-Leuten betrifft. Ich meine, derzeit gehen gehen die Zahlen zurück,
Universitäten, weil das einfach so unattraktiv ist und ähm ich weiß nicht genau, wodurch sich das ändern soll, außer dass dadurch, dass einfach noch mal eine ganze Generation ausstirbt.
Und ich hoffe, ich gehöre da noch nicht dazu,
Ich wollte das schon noch mitkriegen, wenn's im Wald ist.
So wir äh bis bis also was war bis 2025 kriegen, wenn wir uns jetzt nicht hier hinsetzen, ist Chatkontrolle, ne?
Immerhin, das ist auch Cyber und und modern, ja! Maßnahmen, also äh äh die FDP,
FDP ist ja ähm muss man ja sagen immerhin hat sie ihren liberalen Freiheitsgedanken des Marktes
so weit ausgelebt, dass sie den auch den Menschen teilweise zugesteht. Insofern die die liberalen Prinzipien äh der alten äh noch äh von uns auch hochgelobten
FDP unter Sabine äh Lordhäuser Schnarrenberger und Gerd Baum äh kann natürlich äh gedacht werden, wenn sich die FDP sehr,
stark äh gegen die Chatkontrolle. Ähm aus aus äh spricht.
Und zwar hat die FDP mehrere äh rote Linien spezifisch das ähm,
BMJ, also das Bundesministerium der Justiz und das Bundesministerium für Digitales und Verkehr.
Ähm haben einen klare, haben jetzt rote Linien äh definiert, ähm um überhaupt dem Kommissionsentwurf.
Zur Chatkontrolle ähm zustimmen zu können. Sie sagen, es muss klare Vorgaben für den Verläss von Aufdeckungsanordnungen geben, also mit hinreichender
Eingrenzung des erheblichen Risikos und ähm klingt jetzt kompliziert, aber das,
dass du überhaupt quasi unter die Chatkontrolle fällst. Dafür müsste es eine klare Eingrenzung geben, was denn das erhebliche Risiko ist und Vorgaben für die Entscheidung, die da getroffen werden soll. Also weniger Willkür bei der Entscheidung wer jetzt unter Chatkontrolle,
fällt. Es darf keine Regeln geben, die zu einer Chatkontrolle führen. Ähm wegen,
Also insbesondere E-Mail-Dienste, Messenger und so weiter und äh da sagen sie insbesondere, weil im Koalitionsvertrag steht ja Maßnahmen zum Scannen privater Kommunikation und eine Identifizierungspflicht äh,
lehnen wir ab, dann sagen sie persönliche Speicher, die nicht geteilt werden,
Zum Beispiel Cloud Sprecher, die als Backup der eigenen Fotos auf dem Handy dienen, dürfen von den Regelungen zur Aufdeckungsanordnung ausdrücklich nicht erfasst werden.
Ähm Streichung,
auf äh unbekanntes Material und Grooming. Mit anderen Worten keine kein Scannen von Texten, keine KI, die neues Material erkennen soll. Expliziter Ausschluss des Einsatzes von Kleinzeitscanning und Aufhebung der Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung.
Dann Audiokommunikation,
Darf es auszuschließen? Den Anbietern muss es möglich sein, die äh Pflichten, also Risikobewertung, Risikominderung, Löschung Schwerung zu erfüllen ohne den Artikel zehn,
Absatz eins äh beschriebenen Aufdeckungstechnologien und das ist im Text auch so festzulegen. Also du du,
muss im Prinzip Risikobewertungen, Risikominderungen und so weiter irgendwie schon erfüllen können, ohne überhaupt Aufdeckungstechnologien zum Einsatz zu bringen. Ähm die,
Altersverifizierung nur, wenn man es mit,
wenn es mit anonymer und pseudonymer Nutzung in Übereinklang zu bringen ist und keine Einbeziehung von Inhalten oder Verhaltensweisen, die nach nationalem Recht nicht strafbar sind,
Ähm ich denke, das ist hier meine also so.
Eine Ansage.
Komplett. Das ist eine Ansage und da müssen wir auch mal äh ganz klar sagen, äh dass das ist,
wirklich das, was man sich von einer FDP an an dieser Stelle erhoffen muss. Ich muss auch sagen
etwas, was ich mir von den Grünen an dieser Stelle erhofft hätte. Nur ähm im Gegensatz zur FDP sind die natürlich gerade mit den tatsächlichen Problemen des Landes beschäftigt und ähm insofern,
den akuten Problemen. So okay ähm FDP fährt muss ja eher an Porsche Sachen schicken. Nein, genug FDP-Scherze also hier
denke ich, eine sehr ordentliche Positionierung vom Bundesministerium für Digitales und Verkehr und,
vom Bundesministerium der äh Justiz und ähm kann man nur hoffen,
dass das jetzt einen ordentlichen Druck auf ähm Nancy Faser auch äh äh auch ausübt, jetzt endlich ihren ihren Ladendamm in den Griff zu.
Ja und letzten Endes Druck auf die Kommission, vor allem aus.
Ja, natürlich. Ähm jetzt gucken wir mal ganz kurz. Ich habe ja schon jetzt immer nur die Ministerien genannt, äh der Bundesminister für Digitales und Verkehr ist Volker Wissing und,
BMJ ist der deutsch-chinesische Rechtsstaat Dialog. Nein, das Bundes,
so nee, das ist der das ist der Titel der Seite. Ich dachte, das wäre der erste.
Bundesministerium für Justiz.
Genau und das ist der ist der Minister natürlich. Doktor Marco Buschmann.
So und da äh können wir sagen äh Wissing und Buschmann,
haben gute Leute, die hier sehr klar auch in der juristischen Sprache äh klar äh rote Linie aufzeigen und die auch so benennen und das auch der Innenministerin so mitgeteilt haben.
Ja das ist schon ordentlich.
Ja, das mir auch ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen, dass es da nicht so ein Kompromiss kommt, der äh die,
Pläne so wie sich die Usas vorgestellt hat, verhindert oder zumindest stark einschränken,
Also ich sehe jetzt nicht, wie die wie wie die jetzt sozusagen auf EU-Ebene vollständig zustimmen kann, wenn die Gemengelage in der Koalition so ist. Man ist wenn ihr sicherlich bei ihrer Klausur äh idealerweise auch besprochen haben, gucken was dabei rauskommt.
Also ich äh hoffe,
ähm das Nancy Faser sich dann noch von anderen Leuten beraten lässt als die ähm die da bei ihr im Haus sitzen. Ja, sage ich da nicht zu. Österreich hat schon seit vielen Jahren Matchball.
Ein pfiffiges Land.
Aber aber die waren immer Domänen bezogen, also DNS sperren, ne.
Und ähm jetzt hat hat ähm,
hat sich aus irgendwelchen Gründen die Verwertungsgesellschaft LSG äh das ist also die die LSG zur Wahrnehmung von Leistungsschutzrechten GmbH ähm,
sehr schöne Webseite, wirklich irres, irre Webseite. Ähm.
Könnte man mal sperren.
Das ist um das mal kurz.
Keine Webseite.
Mal kurz zu visualisieren, was du da was du da meinst. Das das ist die wortwörtliche Visitenkarte im Netz.
Informationen, Veröffentlichung Interpret-Label und Musikvideo haben die.
Ja, aber es sieht aus wie so eine Visitenkarte.
Dahinter ein Alter, wie geil ist diese Webseite? Das ist die könnte ja fast von mir sein. So.
Wieso? Von dem Minimalismus her.
Ich stehe auf sowas.
Ja deine Visitenkarte im Netz.
Areash. Geil, guck mal, das das geht noch in aktuellem HTML, so eine eine,
die haben halt ein Bild, ja, Einstieg Unterstrich nur JPG. Gucken wir mal, wie die Einstieg JPG aussieht. Äh Einstieg, J Piggy, die liegt da bestimmt auch noch aufm Server.
Nee, vier null vier.
Das Beste hast du noch nicht gar nicht erwähnt an dieser Website?
Kein Cookie-Banner.
Nee. Noch besser. Noch nicht aufgefallen.
Die hat irgendwie, die ist pixelig.
Nee ist noch besser.
Die ist pixelig, aber es ist ein Fund, den man.
Falscher falsche Richtung. Denk mal mehr in deine in dein Spezialgebiet rein.
Ja oben das äh hat TTP in Uhr, ne.
Mhm. Keine Ahnung. Ist schon geil. Das fällt einem mittlerweile auf im Jahr zwanzig zweiundzwanzig.
Metaname oha guck mal und äh die hat äh die hat sehr schöne.
Ist das denn für eine Seite, ey? Also okay, die hat irgendwie vorne.
Zum Inhalt. Also.
Warte mal erst mal.
Tolle LSG, die Verwertungsgesellschaft LSG. Ja, die die wollte dann auch mal was sperren.
Sachen im Internet, böse Sachen müssen gesperrt werden und ähm,
Manchmal reichen einfach Domainnamen nicht. Insbesondere bei so einem Unternehmen, wo man sich mit Domainnamen nicht so gut auskennt und wie man Webseiten anlegt, die auch dem aktuellen Sicherheitsstandard entsprechen.
Ich habe gerade den Webdesigner auf LinkedIn gefunden.
Was machst du da? Komm, lass uns hier.
Seinen Namen als aber der ist seit 1999 im Business. Das sieht man der Webseite auch an. Also sie hat auf jeden Fall eine gewisse Seniorität äh strahlt die auf jeden Fall aus.
Befindet sich auch noch im Jahr neunzehnhundertneunundneunzig. Er kommuniziert mit dem Unternehmen über einen Zeitunnel.
Nach dem neuesten Standards von 1999 erstellt und abgesichert. Ist alles drin. Klickbare Bilder und richtiges HTTP.
Klick Bild sogar.
Okay, wir haben gesagt, wir müssen wir müssen Seiten löschen und das mit diesen dummen wenn man DNS-Sperren macht, ist ja Quatsch, weil dann dann können die Leute ja einfach andere DNS-Server nutzen, ja, das ist ja diese gesamte Diskussion mit und so weiter, wo die GFS sich mit auseinandersetzt.
Also haben die gesagt, hier jetzt löschen wir einfach die äh äh jetzt sperren wir die IP-Adresse. Und dann haben sie ähm,
das geschafft äh nicht eine eine Domain, sondern eben die IP-Adresse. So und,
Adressen von Cloud Flair bei,
und Cloud Fair ist halt ein äh Content Delivery Network, der die bei ungefähr 19 Prozent der zehn Millionen am meisten besuchten Webseiten davorgeschaltet sind. Darunter Wikipedia Fit,
OK QPIT. Behördenärzte NGOs und andere Unternehmen laut äh Applecenter dot works. All diese komplett legalen Angebote, die teilweise essentielle Dienstleistungen äh da darbieten,
wurden,
für mehrere Stunden gesperrt. Äh und äh ja, weil die vor Gericht die Sperrung von Alpir der Firma Cloudflat durchgesetzt hatten.
Und äh Provider wie Magenta und Levest haben die umgesetzt.
Das ist äh tatsächlich schon seit Längerem eine,
Form der ähm sagen wir mal der Zensurumgehung sich halt auf auf,
auf diese Plattform oder auf diese CDs gezielt zu gehen, damit du ähm ja, damit es einfach einen großen Kollateralschaden gibt, ne. Ähm insofern,
man man macht das eigentlich, weil man davon ausgeht, dass es nicht so Idioten gibt ähm die dann eine solche Sperrung tatsächlich auf IP-Ebene machen,
Aber äh ja gibt es,
Und äh das ist sehr sehr sehr spannend. Es gibt übrigens, das ist aber schön, muss man auch sagen, äh zum Beispiel der Provider Leavest,
haben ihre aktuelle Sperrliste auch online. Da sind auch ein paar Seiten bei, die kannte ich noch gar nicht,
Zum die haben eine vollständige Liste ihrer gesperrten Webseiten und das Gute ist, die sind auch direkt als Link klickbar, damit ui, hier guck mal, das neue Album,
von Nicki Minach.
Wesentlichen so war es einfach Filme, Filme, Filme, Filme, Filme.
Metallica.
Ist übrigens auch nur HCTP die Webseite, ne?
Äh die würde ich aber ehrlich gesagt auch direkt mal äh sperren lassen, weil das scheint mir bisher so das Beste.
Sperren Sie doch mal Ihre Netzsperren-Seite. Sehr schön.
Also der was haben wir hier? Oh. Ach herrje.
Äh jetzt ist jetzt bin ich auf die deutsche Sperrseite gekommen von der Kuh. Weil ich hier ähm deutsches Internet habe.
Ja gibt's auch.
Freibeuter, Filme GmbH. Sinne Punkt TO kann ich nicht, da funktioniert das HTTPS nicht. Also gute Liste ähm haben wir mal äh verlinkt und ja also die haben das, die haben das natürlich sehr schnell.
Äh rückgängig gemacht und ähm ja Cloud Flair ist ja äh aufgrund seiner.
Aufgrund ähm seiner Primär-Dedos-Protection wird es genutzt, ist aber aufgrund dieser Dedos Protection bei Tor-Usern,
nicht besonders beliebt ähm oder auch bei VPN-Usern hast dann andauernd,
Diese äh Captures davor, bevor die Seite sehen kannst, ähm aber in diesem Fall ähm helfen sie, denke ich mal, der der Zensur entgegenzutreten.
Schön, jetzt habe ich auch noch mal ein paar neue Domains für äh rausgefunden, die ich noch nicht kannte.
Genau, ne. Gibt noch ein paar schönes Feierabend, ein paar Library Genesis, das ist wirklich also dafür hat es sich schon gelohnt.
Steht auch daneben, wer ist wer ist äh eingeklagt hat, ne. Zwei habe nur El Silvia und so.
Silvia, der weißt du direkt, was es da gibt. Musst du gar nicht erst also Filme, Film GmbH, Film, Produktionsgesellschaft,
Ja, das ist super. Also das ist eine Spitzen das ist ein Link-Tipp. Link-Tipps, das gab's doch früher auch, ne? Da hast du ein Magazin gekauft am Bahnhof und dann gab's Link-Tipps. Wo man wo man hin wo man hinsurfen kann,
Haben wir hier mal einen gemacht jetzt. So, dann haben wir außerdem das Internet wird auch von den Urheberrechts äh äh Leuten verklagt.
Und zwar äh gehen die Verlage davon aus, dass es dort 127 mutmaßliche Urheberrechtsverletzungen gab,
Beim Arcal, beim Internet und äh dafür möchten sie gerne 19 Millionen US-Dollar haben.
Hundertsiebenundzwanzig. Oh Gott. Ja.
Und zwar hat das Internet AKF so eine.
Die haben quasi eine eine Control Digital Landing ähm das wird du musst also ein,
also das Internet AKF hat irgendwie Scans,
und ähm wenn du die jetzt sehen möchtest, dann musst du dich quasi anmelden und durch die Anmeldung gucken sie halt das immer nur einer drauf zugreifen kann. Also du leihst dir das Dokument, das kann jeweils nur einer sehen. Und dadurch ähm
sagt das A-Kreif eben, man leistet eben kurz aus und für den Zeitpunkt wurde das von uns,
geliehen hast, kann es eben niemand anderes sich auch noch anschauen.
Und dann argumentieren die eben, ja, aber die können das ja trotzdem speichern und so weiter und so fort und die das Internet-Arkaff hat das ähm ausgeschaltet,
ähm zu Beginn der ähm,
der Pandemie, weil da sehr viele Bibliotheken geschlossen haben und dann hat die das Internet-Arkalt gesagt, wenn die Bibliotheken jetzt zu haben, machen wir eine nationale,
Notfallbibliothek und sagen ähm ihr könnt jetzt, ne, wir verleihen es mehrfach.
Also ausgeschaltet haben sie diese Funktion, dass es nur einer gleichzeitig ausleihen kann. Das meinst du.
Und das dafür dafür wollen die jetzt 119 Millionen US-Dollar haben. Was sind das für eine 19 Millionen, ja.
Für hundert17undzwanzig Bücher.
Die im Rahmen der Corona-Nothilfe als die Bibliotheken Zuwanderung Menschen zugänglich gemacht wurden.
Heute ist ja äh letzter August. Wo fährst du denn heute noch hin? Mit deinem 9-Euro-Ticket?
Ja. Ich fahre dir wohl mal hin. Ähm ich habe ich habe tatsächlich für August kein Neun-Euro-Ticket.
Ach warum.
Aber weißt du was die weißt du, ich glaube.
Das nehmen Sie nicht im Flugzeug, ne?
Aber ich sage dir eins, das Neu-Euro-Ticket kommt zurück Tim. Weißt du auch wieso? Sonst wird Sylty Punks nie los.
Erzählt, dass ich die gesehen habe.
Die ihr sicher.
Ja ich war ich war ja auf Sylt. Ich habe ja letztes Mal noch erzählt, ich war ja noch nie auf Sylt und ich war ja zwischenzeitlich tatsächlich auf Sylt. Das hat sich ähm zufällig äh ergeben, weil jemand dort ein Zimmer gebucht hat und das dann aber nicht wahrnehmen konnte. Dachte ich mir so fährst du einfach mal auf Sylt,
Geier und das war äh wirklich eine interessante Zeitreise,
Nach Sylt zu fahren, weil kommst dann da irgendwie in diesem Westerland an und,
Und irgendwie hast du das Gefühl, das ist so ein so ein so ein Fleisch gewordener Reisetraum der Siebziger, so,
Also äh als da noch so eine ganz merkwürdige Aufbruchstimmung war in diesem Land und war das so siebziger Jahre Betonklötzchen äh Häuser so als Reisedomizile.
Das sieht alles so ein bisschen aus wie so ein ein liebloses Altersheim wie das andere nebeneinander.
Und äh das Ganze wird so dominiert von so einer Einkaufsstraße. Dann gibt's noch ein ganz putziges Rathaus. Das sieht in der Tat wirklich äh schick aus und der Rest von Sylt hat auch äh
nette Anwesen, allerdings nicht ganz so discountmäßig äh ausgerichtet und dann lief ich irgendwie so an diesem Rathaus vorbei und gegenüber dieses
dieses Rathauses ist so eine Wiese. Und diese ganze Wiese war vollgezeltet mit so Punks.
Die da so demonstriert haben für bezahlbaren Wohnraum.
Schmeckt gut.
Das das war sozusagen ihre Dauer Dauerdem. So den Eindruck äh habe ich gewonnen,
Interessanterweise waren das aber alles äh auch sehr junge Punks. Also es war wirklich mehr so eine Teenager-Veranstaltung und es war ganz putzig zu sehen, wie die sich dann so mit den äh sonstigen Syltreisenden äh da so äh vermischt haben.
Ja, ich war da nur ein paar Tage äh habe habe mal einmal so Sylt abgehakt, äh so als kostenlosen Urlaub für mich und ähm,
Auch beschlossen, dass da jetzt nicht nochmal hinfahren muss, weil fand jetzt toll.
Ja, aber die sind ja jetzt äh dauerhaft gestrandet. Ja sicher, wir sollen in Hause kommen ohne Neu-Euro-Ticket. Meinst du, die.
Ja ich äh bitte jetzt kalt.
Ich würde ich hoffe, dass die jetzt richtig aufdrehen
und da immer immer mehr voll pinkeln und bis dann Sylt höchstpersönlich sagt, wir zahlen euch die Neun-Euro-Tickets. Aber weißt du, wer wer wir können jetzt schon wir können jetzt schon Leuten, die Neun-Euro-Tickets zahlen, ne,
denn,
zum Ende des Neun-Euro-Tickets auch wieder eine sehr schöne äh Idee oder sehr schön umgesetzt. Gibt's den neun Euro-Fonds.
Äh ein Ticket für alle und zwar ist es ein eigentlich eine ähm eine Spendenaktion des Freiheitsfonds,
ähm und da kannst du also sagen, du spendest jetzt einfach regelmäßig 9 Euro,
und damit äh äh also ab September kann jeder 9 Euro für für 9 Euro pro Monat Mitglied werden, wirst du bei einer,
Kontrolle ohne gültigen Fascher getroffen? Bezahlt er dir bezahlt ihr der Fonds das erhöhte Beförderungsentgeld,
Du musst uns nur die Zahlungsaufforderung des jeweiligen Verkehrsunternehmens zu senden und wir überweisen das Entgelt für dich.
Achtung. Das Fahren ohne gültiges Ticket ist immer eine Straftat, auch wenn das erhöhte Beförderungsentgelt im Anschluss bezahlt wird. Verkehrsbetriebe bringen die Straftaten nach Zahlung
bislang,
äh nach Zahlung nur bislang häufig nicht zur Anzeige. Darauf solltest du dich aber nie verlassen, ein Sticker. Für alle gibt's einen Sticker.
Kannst du äh aktiv werden? Ja, also da gibt's das neun Euro Ticket, ganz einfach. Wie oft darf ich ohne gültigen Fahrschein kontrolliert werden?
Wir rufen nicht dazu auf, ohne gültigen Fahrschein zu fahren, aber wenn du in dem Monat, in dem du deine 9 Euro an den Fonds gezahlt hast mit dem Bus, der U-Bahn oder der Tram gefahren bist, übernehmen wir dein erhöhtes Entgelt
auch mehrfach. Das ist.
Das ist eine.
Soll die Ticket kaufen? Kannst also kannst auch mit Anspruch und ohne Anspruch auf Leistung neun Euro vor warum nicht einfach mal die Sachen selber machen, weißt du?
Mal gucken, ob das so gut läuft wie sein äh Befreiungs ähm Projekt, was ist das Thema eigentlich geworden?
Ich glaube, das läuft weiterhin, ne? Der der Freiheitsfond. Also das ist ein gemeinsames Projekt von äh Freiheitsfond. Äh wer hat, der gibt und sanktionsfrei.
Ja. Ich glaube, jetzt mitmachen und weiterfahren. Neun-Euro-Ticket. Ja, gar kein Problem.
So, dann kommen wir zum Ende der Sendung. Also wir sind schon da.
Ich finde das ja wirklich schade, mit dem Hans-Christian Ströbel, ne?
Schön, dass du das das das jetzt.
Zum Ende nochmal.
Mal so ein bisschen na ja ähm,
Wir können uns jetzt nur verabschieden, Minus und wir hoffen, wir machen's noch bis zur nächsten Woche. Dann gibt's auch wieder eine neue Ausgabe Lochbund Netzpolitik.
So wird es sein. Vielen Dank Tim.
Bis dann, Leute. Tschüss.